ce qui fonctionne pas premièrement c'est
quand même les tactiques de lancement
extrêmement rapide de produits donc
beaucoup de marques font exprès ou
essayent qu'on change rapidement nos
produits changent les périphériques
on sait ce qu'on appelle leur sur
l'essence qui est indirecte un peu
l'état se spécialiser là-dessus qu'un et
des nouveaux modèles par exemple
d'iphone les périphériques ne sont plus
les mêmes
donc là on est dans un cas
d'obsolescence indirects tous vos
périphériques vous allez devoir
l'échangé donc il ya cette tactique là
qui ai fait part de mon entreprise ça
c'est assez gênant et la question des
rendre disponibles les pièces détachées
à des coûts qui sont assez raisonnables
ensuite la responsabilité des
détaillants sur certaines catégories de
produits
donc pas de disposer des pièces ne
pousse pas la réparation
ensuite c'est aussi la responsabilité du
consommateur qui ne s'interroge pas au
bout il ya beaucoup d'outils qui sont à
sa disposition sur internet vous allez
tout trouvé il ya plein de sites comment
réparer points comme vous allez trouver
toutes les solutions et il ya ici à des
circuits qui sont assez faciles vous
allez trouver des outils sursis québec
où c'est qu'il ya tout qui existent
cinglant qu'est ce que ça prend pour le
consommateur ça prend du temps ça prend
de s'informer et ça prend aussi de faire
une action spécifique donc il ya un
effort à faire de la part du
consommateur est aujourd'hui dont nous
c'était moderne on peut pas faire
l'effort